this indian porter is using his head to
get the job done
what is occupational health and safety
have to say about that it's absolutely
incredible that he balances a bike on
his head but then he climbs a ladder
this is ridiculous I thought this was
fake how could this be real
how can a man climb a ladder with a
motorcycle on his head it takes four men
just to lift this motorbike onto this
guy's head once it's there the entire
mass is supported by inspire the spine
is made up of a column of alternating
Bones called vertebrae and fibrous
intervertebral discs the fibrous discs
cushion the force and distributed across
the next vertebrae this system is able
to absorb and distribute the compressive
forces of the motorbike on his head
in fact the spinal system works so well
that in theory he could actually carry a
much heavier motorbike of course this
only works when his neck remains
completely vertical if it buckles at any
point then the whole system falls apart
and he's in a whole lot of pain climbing
up a ladder is extremely dangerous
because he could lose balance and the
bike could fall severely injuring his
neck or spine in other words this is
definitely not safer work